this recent paper describes how infusing
biomaterial can potentially treat
inflamed and injured tissue such as the
brain hearts and lungs from the inside
out
so like the biomaterial used in the
study let me digest the key findings
from this paper for you starting with
what these biomaterials are how it was
tested in the paper and look at how
these findings can be therapeutically
translated as regenerative medicines
so firstly what are these bio materials
that we're talking about
well when you are at school you were
probably taught something like the body
is made of cells those cells make up
tissues and those tissues make up organs
and those organs make up organ systems
and those systems work together as a
team to support your body right well
sure but it misses an important point
that is it gives the impression that
just cells make up tissues which just
don't get me wrong part of the story or
but I should say part of the tissue but
in other parts of the tissue that's
really important for its function is the
extracellular Matrix that is unique to
each tissue type
The extracellular Matrix or ECM as I'll
continue to say is the natural
scaffolding and framework in which the
cells of the tissue resides
a perhaps terrible analogy is to say
that the ECM is like the cement that
holds the bricksville altogether and
it's a bad analogy because it's not just
a structural component the ECM can also
mediate by a chemical cues that can
alter a cell's behavior and vice fossil
cell secrete factors that actually
compose this ECM and this all creates
the tissues micro environment
so it's important
and therefore when one talks of damaged
tissue or inflamed tissue you now know
that it may not just mean that the cell
so damaged it is also possible that this
extracellular Matrix has also become
damaged and in fact stiffening off the
ECM through glycation aggregation and
cross-linking and the downstream
physical consequences of this are now
being explored heavily in links with
aging
so what if we can restore replace
recover help out the ECM when a tissue
is inflamed or wounded would that help
one recover faster from injury and down
the line have any potential for
regenerative Therapies
well at least for the former this has
already been tested in humans and it was
done by using ECM biomaterial
effectively isolating components of the
ECM from tissue samples removing all the
cells doing some digestion and
fractionating the sample and then
injecting it back in this first and
human study to determine the safety and
feasibility of this approach 15 patients
who sustained moderate damage and are
left ventricle wool following a heart
attack received the self-assembling ECM
developed by Karen Christman and
colleagues that remains liquid at room
temperature yet forms a gel at body
temperature
here the patients had endomyocardial
injections that is to say it was a
relatively invasive way of applying the
ECM hydrogels the biomaterial had to be
injected into the patient's endocardium
through a catheter using an
electrochemical mapping system
and while the study showed that there's
potential value in this approach they
had to use this approach instead of just
injecting it into the blood because this
gel poses a risk to aggregating by well
gelling and blocking the vascular system
I'm not only is this procedure quite
invasive but because of this method it
cannot be used to treat patients
immediately after the event
so what can be done to improve this
method and hopefully then Downstream
therapeutic application
well that brings us back to this recent
paper
intra-fascularly infused extracellular
Matrix as a biomaterial for targeting
and treating inflamed tissues
this has come out again from the
chrisman's lab who was involved in the
above travel and here they've describes
something called infusible ECM that can
instead be injected intraffenously so
straight into the vascular system which
would therefore be less invasive than
the previous approach
so how did they do it well before we get
to that let's just first go over the
procedure of how they actually attain
this ECM hydrogel it first involves
chopping up part tissue
in this paper they take it from pic Arts
so we get heart tissue and the first
step is we chop it up into tiny pieces
and we put it into a bath like a beaker
right here and Stir It Up with detergent
so to remove all the cellular contents
after a couple days we rinse it out to
remove all the detergents and all we
really have left are the structural
proteins that make up a tissue so we
take that and we freeze dry it into this
styrofoam-like substance it's really
light and crispy so it's freeze-dried
and then we take this and we Mill it
into a fine powder that looks like this
and we take that and digest it with an
enzyme to liquefy it you can see that
there's liquid at the bottom of this and
this little bead is just stirring it up
and keeping everything well mixed
and then finally we take the liquid form
of this and we inject it into the heart
into damaged heart tissue and once the
liquid hits body temperature it forms a
gel that looks like this and it no
longer flows anymore
and so that is the approach used to
create ECM hydrogels but in this paper
they make an infusible ECM gel the
additional steps involve spinning the
sample very fast such that all the
bigger proteins that make the
biomaterial more printer gelling palette
to the bottom of the tube they can then
just keep the so-called supernatant that
contains more of the smaller weight
proteins as this protein gel shows
they've removed effectively the high
weights proteins this includes many
larger collagen proteins
and then the supernatant is sterile
filtered lyophilized and resuspended for
administration
and so unlike the earlier formulation of
the ECM where it gelled in tissue after
injection this infusible ECM didn't gel
when incubated at body temperature in
vitro and the authors also show that
this infusible product is hemocompatible
that is to say that they could mix it
with donor human blood to see if there'd
be any complications with combining this
with the blood system and they showed
that that wasn't to be the case
it was so called hemocompatible
and so that's the biomaterial but does
it actually have new therapeutic value
well remember I said here that they want
to have an intervascular infusion
delivery methods now an introvascular
methods would effectively transport the
biomaterial throughout the body
but they wanted to go to the regions of
damage so they firstly tested this in
vitro so when the cell culture with
endothelial cells that are the cells
that make up the vascular lining and
they did this with untreated controls
scratched and therefore damaged cells or
inflamed cells and by staining about
infusible ECM Reds what you can clearly
see is that the biomaterial in red was
binding when the cells were injured or
in flames
but obviously we kind of want to know if
this why it's in Vivo so in the in the
body and they did this by testing it in
different animal models both in acute
and chronic diseases
here they tested acute myocardial
infarction traumatic brain injury and
Pulmonary arterial hypertension
in all cases they saw that this
infusible ECM when delivered to the
animals filled the gaps between the
endothelial cells and it didn't bind to
the neighboring healthy tissue showing
that it was localizing to the regions of
damage and they further examined this in
myocardial infarction and both rats and
pig models and saw that it reduced
vascular leakiness in the tissue and
improved cardiac function so to quote
Chrisman this new form of ECM
biomaterial can be delivered minimally
invasively through either intra-coronary
infusion or even simple intravenous
infusion to target areas of damaged or
inflamed tissue to stimulate tissue
repair
the unexpected finding that the
infusible ECM binds to Leaky fascular
and reduces vascular leakage which is
known to exacerbate damage in the heart
of the myocardial infarction was
particularly exciting as it opened up
the possibility of using this material
to treat not only the heart but also in
many other tissues where there is
inflammation and leaky fasculature
that said there are still some many
unanswered questions with this approach
firstly what is the actual mode of
action of the material besides the fact
it just seems to be binding to the
regions of damage what actually composes
the biomaterial and what are the main
protein or peptide components that are
contributing to its function
if it is filling the gaps between the
endothelial cells could a synthetic
material with similar function be
developed as in the study they derived
the material from a pig's heart which
while is available is something that
many may have ethical issues with
and was ECM therefore derived from other
organs also performed similarly for
sealing off leaky vessels does it have
to come from the heart
but as described by one of the
co-authors Ryan Reeves an Interventional
cardiologist
the logistics of a randomized clinical
trial of treating patients with an acute
myocardial infarction with this novel
injectable material would not be very
complex the same catheters that are used
to diagnose and treat and acutely
occluded coronary artery could be used
to deliver the infusible ECM or a
placebo
so it seems sometime soon we could
really see application of healing the
body from the inside out
now while I don't know you who is
listening Inside Out YouTube thinks that
those and reckons you will enjoy this
video here
so with that I hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening